[Musique] le
novichok est
un agent neurotoxique très sophistiqué de qualité militaire,
il est plus puissant que le sarin et le vx, ce qui
signifie qu'une dose plus faible est nécessaire pour
produire un effet mortel. Ce qui se
passe, c'est que le système nerveux se
déclenche de manière extravagante
et vous obtenez ainsi tous ces éléments bizarres.
symptômes de paralysie
et de convulsions en même temps
le monde devient très sombre et devient
très très flou
ils commencent aussi à saliver et les
poumons commencent à sécréter
vous savez beaucoup de liquide dans l'espoir d'
essayer de contrer cet agent
et donc quelqu'un le trouve
Des composés de Novichok incroyablement difficiles à respirer ont en fait été
fabriqués dans les années 70 et 80 dans l'
ancienne Union soviétique.
La raison pour laquelle ils ont été fabriqués
était qu'ils
voulaient contourner le traité sur les armes chimiques.
Pour ce faire, ils ont fabriqué deux
composants distincts qui n'étaient pas  -toxique
qui, une fois mélangé,
formerait un agent neurotoxique et
la gravité de l'action était supérieure
à celle des
agents neurotoxiques précédents connus, il a été
développé
en Russie et a tout testé en tant
qu'arme
uniquement en Russie dans n'importe quel pays, dans aucun
autre pays, bien qu'ils ne le fassent pas
avoir
des informations à ce sujet
à cause de cela, c'est un monopole de
[Musique]
Russie
je me sens coupable parce que j'ai
aidé j'ai participé à cette
affaire criminelle j'ai été la création de ces
méchants je mais je ne
suppose jamais que  il serait
utilisé par des
filles terroristes à cause de ça, j'ai
été choqué
mais je me sens coupable